consider a segment AB how would the
perpendicular bis sector of this segment
look as the name says it has to be
perpendicular and it has to BCT the
segment let line L be the perpendicular
bis sector of this segment and say it
intersects AB at Point
C this will be a right angle and length
of AC will equal length of BC C the
perpendicular bis sector of a segment
divides that segment into two equal
parts and is also perpendicular to it
let's erase this and look at
perpendicular bis sectors in a
triangle consider triangle
pqr if we draw a perpendicular bis
sector of each side of a triangle in all
we will have three of them the angle bis
sectors of all the angles of a triangle
always meet at a point but do the
perpendicular bis sectors of the sides
of a triangle also meet at a single
point let line L be the perpendicular
bis sector of segment
PQ these two sides will be equal and
this will be a right angle let line M be
the perpendicular bis sector of side
QR that will make these two sides equal
and this angle a right angle now we have
to see
if the perpendicular bis sector of
segment p r passes through this point
let line n be the perpendicular bis
sector of segment p r and yes it passes
through the same point this side will
equal this side and line n will be
perpendicular to p r so even the
perpendicular bis sectors of the
triangle meet at Point c one single
point what is this point called it's
called the circumcenter
we had seen that the in center of the
triangle will always lie inside the
triangle but does the circum Center
always lie inside the triangle we see
that in the next part of the
[Music]
video